- All right.
We always like to wrap up with something
that highlights good in the world.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(vibrant band music)
(audience cheering and applauding)
About a year ago I met two sisters,
doing something simple but extraordinary.
They craft cool origami pieces,
collect donations for them,
and use the money to
build fresh water wells
all over the globe.
In 10 years they have raised
more than $3.5 million.
(audience cheering and applauding)
This is incredible.
Now they're busier than ever.
Let's get the founders of Paper for Water
in here for an update.
What's up, Isabelle and Katherine?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Hi, Kelly.
- All right, so-
- Hello.
So, ladies, tell us
about your latest well.
Isabelle, we'll start with you.
- Yeah, so we were able to build a well
in Santa Elena, Peru.
This is a super remote community,
and for decades they hadn't been able
to build a well there,
because of how remote it is.
And so people were having
to get water from the river,
which is full of bacteria
and other contaminants.
- Mm.
- And multiple times a day
people were having to haul
water for their families,
which meant people couldn't go to work,
kids couldn't go to school,
and people were often sick,
so they would have to spend
money on medical costs.
But, thanks to the $10,000 we
got on your show last time,
- Yeah.
- these people now have safe,
clean, easily accessible water.
- That is so incredible.
Shout out to ATB.
That's how we got that 10 grand.
Oh, my gosh. Catherine, that's just part
of what you've been up to though, right?
- Yes.
After being on the show, we
got so many online orders.
We were able to use that money
for a major project in Kenya,
at an orphanage.
We drilled a deep water well in December
and are now constructing
hand washing stations
and an elevated water tank.
It's so important,
because they hadn't had
clean water in years
and we have a bunch of schools in Africa
on our list this year,
and our 10th anniversary book,
"One Piece of Paper at a Time" is out.
- Oh, my gosh. That's
incredible, you guys.
I love what you're doing
for all those little babies.
Oh, and that picture. That's so cool.
Like you're so young to
be doing such rad stuff.
Thank you for showing everybody
that it's possible
(audience applauding)
to make simple like,
but really effective
change that's necessary.
Thank you so much, Isabelle.
Thank you so much, Katherine.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- [Isabelle] Thank you.
- That's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot,
pen makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and impacting the world in big ways,
just like y'all.
So, they're gonna give
Paper for Water a $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Wow.
- Thank you.
- That's amazing.
- Absolutely, ladies.
We love what you're doing.
(audience cheering)
Thank you for joining us again
(audience applauding)
and thank you to all our guests this hour,
Wilma Valderama, Scott
Horn and Kate the chemist.
Y'all have a great day,
(audience cheering)
and if it's not, try and change it.